Porque claro amigos,
todo esto, toda esta locura que estamos viviendo
y lo de los decretos,
etc. tiene sus colaboradores.
O sea, Sánchez
es 1 pollo sin cabeza, ¿eh?
Que que que ya es 1 carrera hacia adelante
sin saber dónde VA o sabiendo muy bien dónde VA.
Ojo, las cosas como son.
Pero hay colaboradores
y 1 de ellos ha sido coalición Canaria.
Miren el voto de coalición Canaria,
salva los decretos de Sánchez.
Señor Araujo, coalición Canaria
que votó a favor de fijo,
que está gobernando con el partido popular en Canarias,
salva los decretos de Pedro Sánchez.
De hecho el decreto onibus lo salva conexión Canaria
y luego el otro decreto también.
Esto bueno y el y el tercero lo pasa,
que podemos se lo tumba,
pero en definitiva esto es 1 vergüenza.
Que unos señores como los canarios,
que se suponen que son de derechas y y que eh
defenden estado derecho,
estén colaborando en 1 golpe de estado.
No, esto realmente
aquí ya no hay ni derecha ni izquierda,
aquí directamente
es cuestión de dinero,
aquí es corrupción directamente
cada cual barre para su casa sin importar absolutamente
ni el estado derecho,
ni los intereses de la ciudadanía,
ni el interés público.
No interesa absolutamente nada,
nada más que el dinero.
El dinero es lo que manda en la política española,
señoras y señores, y todo lo demás valores
Han quedado realmente en 1/2 plano.
Se puede decir 1 cosa y la contraria al siguiente Día
alisión Canaria,
lo mismo forma gobierno con el PP, que forma con el Zoe,
puede formar,
incluso con Bildu o con quien sea, le da lo mismo.
Aquí lo que manda es el billete,
está clarísimo